3 yvelinois tente en ce moment
d'apprivoiser les vents et de dompter
les vagues sur ce vendée globe 2016
les versaillais tanguy de lamotte et
éric bellion et laurent boli teint louis
burton sont partis à l'aventuré sur ce
tour du monde en solitaire et sans
escale au pointage de 15 heures ce
mercredi 9 novembre
imoca initiative coeur de tanguy de
lamotte et classé à la 9e place à bord
d'initiative coeur on vient de passer la
zone interdite du dst du cap finistère
et on à hisser le gennaker avec les
dauphins
bon après midi et bonne soirée à tous
c'est parti pour le tour du mondial de
son côté éric bellion sur comme un seul
homme est installé à la 27ème position
pour son premier vendée globe le skipper
garde le moral
alors pensez
l'arc en ciel
le troisième il vinoy louis burton qui
avait dû abandonner en 2012 suite à une
collision avec un chalutier est pour
l'instant la 16e place avec son imoca
bureau vallée il vient de dépasser le
néo zélandais conrad colman à au large
du portugal
cette huitième édition du vendée globe
est toujours dominé par le fond c'est
armel le cléac'h sur banque populaire